foreign
yes
ah
so
[Music]
is president
good morning everyone
can i please ask you colleagues to have
a seat
their colleagues
their colleagues
dear colleagues could i please you all
ask you to have a seat please
so good morning good morning dear
colleagues good morning the sitting is
open
this morning's item on the agenda is the
statement by the president of the
european commission on the state of the
union a dear president we are all very
much looking forward to it i will start
by giving you the floor
thank you mr president honorable members
i think many are the people
who feel their lives have been on pause
while the world has been on fast forward
because the speed of the events and the
enormity
of the challenges
are sometimes very difficult to grasp
and this has also been a time of
soul-searching
people are re-evaluating their own lives
we are having wider debates on shared
vaccines and shared values
but as i look back on this past year and
if i look at the state of the union
today
i see a strong soul in everything what
we do
it was robert schumann
who said
europe needs a soul
an ideal
and the political will to serve this
ideal
and europe has brought those words to
life in the last 12 months
in the biggest global health crisis for
a century
we chose to go it together
so that every part of europe had access
to the life-saving vaccines
in the deepest global economic crisis
for decades
we chose to go it together
with next generation eu
and in the gravest planetary crisis of
all time again
we chose to go it together
with the european green deal we did it
together as a commission
and i think from the bottom of my heart
my outstanding college of commissioners
for the enormous support during that
time
we did it together
as a parliament with 27 member states as
one europe and i think we can be proud
of it
[Applause]
but corona times are not over
and there is still
much grief in our society as the
pandemic lingers
there are hearts
we can never mend
life stories we can never finish
and time we can never give back
to our young
we face new and enduring challenges in a
world recovering and fracturing unevenly
so there is no question
the next year will be another test of
character
but i believe
it is when you are tested
that your spirit
your soul truly shines through
and as i look across our union
i know that europe will pass the test
and what gives me that confidence
is the inspiration we can draw from
europe's young people
because our youth put meaning
into empathy
and solidarity
they believe we have a responsibility
towards the planet
and while they are anxious about the
future
they are determined to make it better
our union will be stronger
if it is more like our next generation
reflective
determined
and caring
grounded in values
and bold in action
and this spirit will be more important
than ever over the next 12 months
this is the message in the letter of
intent i sent this morning to president
sasali and prime minister janza to
outline our priorities for the year
ahead
honorable members
a year is long in
at the time of pandemics
when i stood here in front of you 12
months ago i did not know when or even
if we could have a safe and effective
vaccine against covet 19.
but today
against all critics
europe is among the world leaders
more than 70 percent of our adult
population is fully vaccinated
we were the only ones
to share
half of our vaccine production with the
rest of the world we delivered more than
700 million doses of vaccines to the
europeans
we delivered
indeed we delivered also more than 700
million to the rest of the world to more
than 130 countries
and we are the only region in the world
to achieve that
honorable members a pandemic is a
marathon it's not a sprint
we follow the science we deliver to
europe we deliver to the rest of the
world we did it the right way because we
did it the european way and i think it
worked
but while we have every reason to be
confident
we have no reason to be complacent
our first and most urgent priority is to
speed up global vaccination
with less than one percent of global
doses administered in low-income
countries
the scale of injustice and the level of
urgency
is obvious
this is one of the great geopolitical
issues in our time
team europe is investing 1 billion euro
to ramp up mrna production capacity with
africa
we have already committed to share 250
million doses of vaccine
i can announce today
that the commission
will add a new donation
of another 200 million doses until the
middle of next year this is an
investment in solidarity and it is an
investment also in global health
the second priority
is to continue our efforts here in
europe
we see worrisome divergences between
member states what vaccination rates are
concerned
so we need to keep up the momentum and
europe is ready
we have 1.8 billion additional doses
secured this is enough for us and our
neighborhood when booster shots are
needed
so let's do everything possible
that this does not turn into a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
and my third point
the final priority is to strengthen
our pandemic preparedness
last year
i said it was time to build a european
health union
today we are delivering
with our proposal we get the hera
authority up and running
this will be a huge asset to deal with
future health threats
earlier and better we have the
innovation in scientific capacity
we have the private sector knowledge we
have competent national authorities
and now we have to bring all that
together including
massive funding
so i am proposing a new health
preparedness and resilience mission
for the whole of the european union
and it should be backed up
by team europe investment of 50 billion
by 2027
to make sure
that no virus will ever turn
a local epidemic again in a global
pandemic there is no better return on
investment than that
honorable members
the work on the european health union is
a big step forward
and i want to thank this house
for your support
we have shown
that when we act together we can act
fast
take the eu digital certificate
today more than 400 million certificates
have been generated across europe
42 countries
in four different continents are plugged
in
we proposed it in march you pushed hard
you helped enormously three months later
three months later only it was up and
running so while the rest of the world
was talking about europe just did it
and we did a lot of things right
we moved fast to create sure
this supported over 31 billion million
workers and 2.5 million companies across
europe
we learned the lessons from the past
when we were too divided
and too delayed
and the difference is stuck
last time it took us eight years for the
eurozone gdp to get back to pre-crisis
level this time
we expect 19 countries to be at
pre-pandemic levels this year
with the rest following next
growth in the euro area outpaced both
the us and china
in the last quarter
but this is only the beginning
and the lessons from the financial
crisis could serve as a cautionary tale
at that time europe declared victory too
soon
and we paid the price for that
and we will not repeat that mistake
the good news is
that with next generation eu
we will both invest in short-term
recovery
and in the long-term prosperity
we will address structural issues in our
economy from labor market reforms in
spain to pension reforms in slovenia or
to tax reforms in austria for example
in an unprecedented manner
we will invest in 5g and fiber
but equally important is the investment
in digital skills this is such an
important topic this task needs leaders
attention and it needs a structured
dialogue at top level we really have to
emphasize that and put a strong focus on
it
our response provides a clear direction
to market
and investors alike
but as we look ahead
we also need to reflect on how
the crisis has affected
the shape of our economy from increased
debts
to uneven impact on different sectors
on new ways of working
and to do that
the commission will relaunch the
discussion
on the economic governance review in the
coming weeks
the aim is
to build a consensus on the way forward
well ahead of 2023
honourable members we will soon
celebrate
30 years of single market
for 30 years it has been the great
enabler of progress
and prosperity in europe at the outset
of the pandemic
we had to defend it
against the pressures of erosion and
fragmentation
for our recovery
the single market is the driver of good
jobs and competitiveness
and that is particularly important in
the digital single market
we have made ambitious proposals in the
last year
for example to contain the gatekeeper
power of the major platforms
to underpin their democratic
responsibilities of those platforms
to foster innovation to channel the
power of artificial intelligence
digital is the make or break issue
and member states also share that view
for example if you look at the digital
spending and next generation you and you
know we have a 20 target
we will even overshoot that 20
target that is good
that reflects the importance and of
investing in our european tech
sovereignty
but allow me to focus on semiconductors
for a moment
these tiny chips that make everything
work
from smartphones
to electric scooters from trains
to entire smart
factories there is no digital without
those chips
and while we speak
whole production lines are already
working at reduced speed speed despite
growing demand
because of a shortage of semiconductors
and while global demand has exploded
europe's share across the entire value
chain
from the design of manufacturing
capacities
has shrunk
we depend right now on state-of-the-art
ships manufactured by asia
so this is not just a matter of our
competitiveness
this is also a matter of tech
sovereignty
so let's put all our forces in it to
improve this situation
we will present a new european chips act
we need to link together
a world-class research design and
testing capacities
we need to coordinate the european level
and the national investment along the
value chain
and the aim is to jointly create a
state-of-the-art european chip ecosystem
including production
that ensures our security of supply
and will develop new markets for
ground-breaking european
tech and yes i know this is a daunting
task without any questions a big big
goal that i put out there and i know
there are some now that claim it cannot
be done
but they have that said the same 20
years ago about galileo galileo
and now look where we are
we got our act together
today europe's satellite provide the
navigation system for more than 2
billion smartphones worldwide
so we did it once we are world leaders
in galileo now let's be bold again and
let's focus all our forces on the
semiconductors and let's go and be a
world leader again this should be our
aim
[Applause]
beneficiary
m
contribution
[Applause]
be
is
european
is
european
[Applause]
i
conference
[Applause]
honorable members
this is a generation with a conscience
they are pushing us to go further and
faster
to tackle the climate crisis
and the events of the summer only served
to explain why
we saw floods in belgium and germany
and wildfires burning from greek to the
hills in france
and if we don't believe our own eyes we
only have to follow the science
the united nations recently published an
ipcc report the intergovernmental panel
on climate change
it is the authority
on the science of climate change
the report leaves no doubt
climate change
is only man made
but since it is man-made we can do
something about it
as i heard it safe
it's warming it's us
we're sure
it's bad
but we can fix it
and change is already happening more
electric vehicles than diesel cars were
registered in germany in the first half
of this year
poland is now the eu's largest exporter
of batteries and electric buses
or take the new european bauhaus
that led to an explosion of creativity
of architects designers engineers across
our union
and if the european green deal has a
soul
then it is the new european bauhaus
so clearly something is on the move
and this is what the european green deal
is all about
in my speech last year i announced our
target
of at least 55
emission reduction by 2030.
since then
we have together
turned our climate goals into legal
obligations
and we are the first major economy
to present comprehensive legislation in
order to get it done
you've seen the complexity of the
detail but the goal is simple
we will put a price on pollution
we will clean the energy we use
we will have smarter cars
and cleaner airplanes
and we will make sure
that higher climate ambition
comes with more social ambition
because this must be a fair green
transition
and this is why we propose the new
social climate fund to tackle the energy
poverty
that already
34 million europeans suffer from
so i count on both
parliament
and member states to keep the package
and to keep the ambition together
when it comes to climate change and the
nature crisis
europe can do a lot
and it will support others
i am proud to announce today
that the european union will double
its external funding for biodiversity in
particular for the most vulnerable
countries
but europe cannot do it alone
the cup 26 in glasgow
will be a moment of truth for the global
community
major economies
from the us to japan
have set ambitions for climate
neutrality in 2050 or shortly after
that's good
but they need now to be backed up by
concrete plans in time for glasgow
because current commitments for 2030
will not keep global warming at 1.5
soldiers within reach
every country has a responsibility
the goals that president xi has set out
for china are encouraging but we call
for that same leadership
on setting out how china will get there
the world would be relieved if they
showed they could peak emissions by
mid-decade and move away from coal at
home and abroad
but while every country
has a responsibility
major economies like us
do have a special duty
to the least
developed and the most vulnerable
countries
the so-called climate finance
is essential for them
both for mitigation
and adaptation
in mexico and in paris
the major economies committed to provide
100 billion dollars a year until 2025
to the least developed and most
vulnerable countries
we deliver on our commitments
team europe contributes 25 billion
dollars a year
but others still leave a gaping hole
towards reaching the global target
so closing that gap
will increase the chance of success in
glasgow
my message today is
that europe is ready to do more
we will now propose an additional 4
billion euro
for climate finance until 2027.
but we expect the united states and our
partners to step up too
this is vital because closing the
climate finance gap together the us and
the european union would be such a
strong signal for global climate
leadership and it is time to deliver now
we have no time to wait anymore
honourable members
this climate and economic leadership
is central to europe's global and
security objectives
it also reflects a wider shift in world
affairs at a time of transition
for the new international order
we are entering a new era
of hyper competitiveness
an era in which some stop at nothing
to gain influence from vaccine promises
to high-interest loans from missiles to
misinformation
an era of regional rivalries and major
powers refocusing their attention
towards each other
recent events in afghanistan
are not the cause of this change
but they are a symptom of it
and first and fore and foremost i want
to be clear
we stand by the afghan people
we stand by the afghan people the women
and children prosecutors journalists and
human rights defenders
i think in particular of women judges
who are now in hiding from the men they
jailed
they have been put at risk for their
contribution to justice
and the rule of law
we must support them and we will
coordinate all efforts with member
states to bring them to safety
and we must continue supporting all
afghans in the country and in
neighboring countries
we must do everything to avert the real
risk that is out there of a major famine
and the humanitarian disaster
and we will do our part
we will increase again
humanitarian aid for afghanistan by 100
million euro
this will be part of a new
wider afghan support package
that we will present in the next weeks
to combine all our efforts
honorable members
witnessing and events unfold in
afghanistan
was profoundly painful
for the families and friends
of fallen servicemen and service women
we bow
to the sacrifice
of those soldiers diplomats and aid
workers
who laid down their lives for our common
cause
to make sure that their service will
never be in vain
we have to reflect on how this mission
could end so abruptly
they are deeply troubling questions that
allies will have to tackle within nato
but there is simply no security and
defense issue
where less
cooperation is the answer
so we need to invest in our joint
partnership and draw on each side's
unique strength
and this is why we are working with
secretary general jens stoltenberg on a
new eu nato joint declaration to be
presented before the end of the year
but
this is only one part
of the equation
europe can and clearly should
be able and willing
to do more on its own
but if we are to do more
we first need to explain why
i see three broad categories
first
we need to provide stability in our
neighborhood
and across different regions
we are connected to the world by narrow
straits stormy seas and vast land
borders
and because of that geography
europe knows better than anyone else
that if you don't deal in time with a
crisis abroad
this crisis will come to you
secondly
the nature of the threats we face
is evolving rapidly
from hybrid to cyber attacks to the
growing arms race in space
we see that disruptive technology has
been the great equalizer in the way
power can be used today by rocks states
and non-state groups
you no longer need an army or missile to
cause mass damage
you can paralyze industrial plants city
administrations and hospitals
all you need is your laptop
you can disrupt
entire elections with a smartphone and
an internet connection
and the third reason is
that our european union is a unique
security provider
there will be missions
where nato or the united nations will
not be present
but where europe should be
on the ground our soldiers work side by
side with police officers lawyers and
doctors with humanitarian workers and
human rights defenders with teachers and
engineers
we can combine military and civilian
alongside with diplomatic and
development
and we have a long history
in building and protecting peace
the good news is that over the past
years we have started to develop kind of
a european defense ecosystem
but what we need now
is the european defense union
in the last weeks
there have been many discussions on
expeditionary forces
on what type and how many we need battle
groups and eu entry forces
this is no doubt part of the debate
and i think it will be part of the
solution
but the more fundamental issue is
why this has not worked in the past
you can have the most advanced forces in
the world but if you're never prepared
to use them of what use are they
what has held us back until now
is not just a shortfall of capacity
it is the lack of political will
and if we develop this political will
there's a lot
that we can do at eu level
allow me to give you three concrete
examples first
we need to build a foundation for
collective decision making and this is
what i call situational awareness
we fall short if member states active in
the same reason do not share their
information at the eu level
it is vital that we improve intelligence
cooperation but this is not just about
intelligence in the narrow sense
it is about bringing together
the knowledge from all services and all
sources from space
to police trainers from open source to
development agencies
the european union could have
a unique scope and depth of knowledge
it's out there
but we can only use that information and
make decisions
if we have the full picture and this is
currently not the case we have the
knowledge but it is disjoint
we have the information but it is
fragmented
and this is why
the european union could consider its
own
joint situational awareness center to
fuse all of these different pieces of
information
and to be better prepared
to be fully informed and thus to be able
to decide
secondly
we need to improve interoperability
this is why we're already investing in
common european platforms from fighter
jets to drones and cybers you know that
but we have to keep thinking of new ways
to use all the possible synergies
one example could be
to consider waving
value-added tax the vit
when buying defense equipment developed
and produced in
europe
this would not only increase our
interoperability
but it would also decrease
our dependencies of today
and the third point is
we cannot talk about defense without
talking about cyber
if everything is connected everything
can be hacked
and given that resources are scarce
scarce
we have to bundle our forces
and we should not just be satisfied
to address the cyber threat
but also strive to become a leader in
cyber security
it should be here in europe where cyber
defense tools are developed
and this is why we need a european cyber
defense policy including legislation on
common standards under a new european
cyber resilience act
so we can do a lot at eu level
but member states need to do more too
and this starts with a common assessment
of the threats we face
and a common approach to dealing with
them
the upcoming strategic compass is the
key process to this discussion
and we need to decide
how we can use
all the possibilities that are already
in the treaty
and this is why under the french
presidency
president macron
and i will convene a summit on european
defense
honourable members it is time for europe
to step up to the next level
[Applause]
in a more contested world protecting our
interest is not only about defending
ourselves
it is also about forging strong and
reliable partnerships
this is not a luxury it is essential for
our future stability security and
prosperity
and this work starts by deepening our
partnership with our closest allies with
the united states we will develop our
new agenda for global change
from the new tech and technology council
to health security and sustainability
the european union and the united states
will always be stronger together
and of course the same goes for our
neighbors in the western balkan
before the end of the month
i will travel to the region to send a
strong signal of our commitment to the
accession process
we owe it to all those young people who
believe in a future in europe
and this is why we're ranking up our
support through our new investment and
economic plan
with around a third of the region's gdp
because honorable members investment in
the future of the western balkan
is an investment in the future of the
european union
and we will also continue investing in
our partnership in our neighborhood
from stepping up on engagement in the
eastern partnership to implementing the
new agenda of the mediterranean
and continuing to work on the different
aspects of our relationship to turkey
honourable members if europe is to
become
a more global player
it also needs to focus on the next
generation of partnerships
in this spirit
today's new eu indo-pacific strategy is
a milestone
it reflects the glowing importance of
the region to our prosperity and our
security
but it also reflects the fact that
autocratic regimes use it
to try to expand their influence
europe needs to be more active
and to be more present in the region so
we will work together to deepen trade
links
strengthen global supply chains and
develop new investment projects on the
green and digital technologies
this is a template
for how
europe can redesign
its model to connect the world
we're pretty good at financing roads
but it does not make any sense for
europe
if we build a perfect road between a
copper that is chinese copper mine that
is chinese owned and a harbor that is
chinese owned
so we have to get smarter when it comes
to this kind of investment
and this is why we will soon present our
new connectivity strategy
called global gateway
we will build global gateway
partnerships with countries around the
world
we want investment in quality
infrastructure
connecting people goods and services
around the world
we will take a values-based approach
offering transparency
and good governance to our partners
we want to create links
and not dependencies
and we know that this can work
since the summer the new underwater
fiber optic cable has connected brazil
to portugal
we will invest with africa
to create a market for green hydrogen
that connects the two shores of the
mediterranean
we need a team global approach to make
global gateway happen
we will connect institutions and
investment banks and business community
and we will make this a priority for
regional summits starting with the next
eu africa summit
in february
we want to turn global gateway
into a trusted brand
around the world
and let me be very clear about one more
point
doing business around the world is good
global trade
around the world
that is good and necessary
but this can never ever be done
at the expense of people's dignity and
freedom
today
there are around 25 million people out
there who are threatened
or coerced
into forced labor
we can never accept
that they are forced to make products
and that these products then end up for
sale here in shops in europe so we will
propose a ban on products on our market
that have been made by forced labor
because human rights are not for sale at
any price
[Applause]
and honorable members human beings are
not bargaining chips look at what
happened at our borders with belarus
the regime in minsk has instrumentalized
human beings
they have put people on planes and
literally pushed them towards europe's
border this can never be tolerated and
the quick european reaction shows that
and rest assured we will continue to
stand together with lithuania latvia and
poland and let's call it what it is it
is a hybrid attack to destabilize europe
we'll never tolerate that
these are not isolated events we saw
similar incidents at other borders and
we can expect to see it again
and this is why as part of our work on
schengen
we will set out new ways
to respond to such aggression
and ensure unity in protecting our
external borders
but as long as we do not find common
ground
on how to manage migration
our opponents will continue to target
this
meanwhile human traffickers continue to
exploit people through deadly routes
across the
mediterranean and these events show us
that every country has a stake in
building a european migration system
the new pact on migration and asylum
gives us everything we need
to manage the different types of
situations we face
all the elements are there
this is a balanced and humane system
that works for all member states and all
circumstances
we know that we can find common
ground but in the years since the
commission presented the pact
progress has been painfully slow
and i think this is the moment now
for european migration management policy
so i urge this house and the member
states to speed up the process
this ultimately comes down to a question
of trust
trust between member states
trust
for europeans that migration can be
managed
trust that europe will always live up
to its enduring duty
to the most vulnerable
and most in need
i know that there are many strongly held
views on migration in europe
but i believe the common ground is not
so far away
because if you ask most europeans
they would agree
that we should act to curb irregular
migration but they would also agree
that we have to act to provide a refuge
to those forced to flee
they would agree that we should return
those who have no right to stay
but they would also agree that we should
welcome those who come here legally and
make such a vital contribution to our
society and our economies
and we should all agree that the topic
of migration should never be used to
divide us
i am convinced
that there is a way
that europe can build trust amongst us
when it comes to migration
of democracy
vietnam
m
is
[Applause]
daphne caruana galicia
jan kuczyak
peter de frisc
[Music]
the highness is
democracy
honourable members
strengthening schumann's
european idea
that i invoked earlier is a continuous
work
and we should not hide away
from our inconsistencies
and imperfections
but in imperfect as we might be
our union is both
beautifully unique
and uniquely beautiful
it is a union where we strengthen our
individual liberty
through the strength of our community
a union shaped as much by our shared
history and values
as by our different cultures and
perspectives
it is a union with a soul
trying to find the right words to
capture the essence of this feeling
is not easy
but it is easier when you borrow them
from someone who inspires you
and this is why
i have invited
a guest of honor
to be with us today
many of you might know her
a gold medalist from italy
who captured my heart this summer
but what you might not know is
that only in april
she was told her life was in peril
she went through surgery
she fought back
she recovered
and only
119 days after she left the hospital she
won paralympic gold honorable members
please join me in welcoming baby yo
thanks enough
[Applause]
baba has overcome so much
so young
her story is one of rising against all
of
of succeeding thanks to talent
tenacity
and unrelenting positivity
she is the image of her generation a
leader and advocate for the causes she
believes in
and she has managed to achieve all of
that
by living up to her belief
that if it seems impossible
then it can be done
far
and this was the spirit of our european
founders and this is the spirit of
europe's next generation
so let's be inspired by babe and by all
the young people who change our
perception of the possible
who show us that you can be
what you want to be and that you can
achieve whatever you believe in
honorable members that is the soul of
europe
that is the future of europe let's make
it stronger viva le europa
[Applause]
thank you very much president wander
lyon i now invite the speakers on behalf
of the political group starting with the
european people's party group and
manfred weber
vice president mitzola
president fonder line minister
dear colleagues the ladies and gentlemen
debating
the state of the union means today the
first focus on what the pandemic has
brought
not everything went well and smoothly
but all in all europe has managed the
crisis well
no other continent has developed a
vaccine
in a better quality
no other continent has a higher
vaccination rate
no other continent has shown more
solidarity and willingness to help each
other
and no other continent has provided
other parts of the world with more
vaccines than we have
all europe is proud of our everyday
heroes the doctors and nurses
researchers and many others and we thank
them for their contribution
the crisis dear friends began in china
in europe we found the solutions we can
be proud about what europeans achieved
in the past
your colleagues when we
look now what is in front of us
then there are two main issues we are
emerging stronger from the crisis but
this crisis has caused and left deep
social and economic wounds many people
fear for their existence for their jobs
only if we create jobs
then we can secure our prosperity and we
can care about the weakest in our
society and we will defend the european
way of life
alongside the green deal
we are thinking as epp that now is also
time for a chops deal
and in addition to this after
afghanistan we
really need now a common foreign and
defense policy joe biden is clear the us
is no longer a world police man
but where is europe russia and china are
just waiting to fill the vacuum and that
would be fatal for the future we would
wake up in a world in which we and also
our children will not want to live
that's based on these two points i want
to make very concrete proposals for what
do we have to do now firstly
the rapid development of a vaccine was
only possible because the authorities
worked quickly during the approval
process that it was the was the biotech
founders told us
no blockades but this speed is what we
also need now in other fields of the
research sector
and in the investments for the climate
protection
with an immediate action plan
for cutting bureaucracies in the
european union we should work together
with all stakeholders to identify 300 eu
regulations that we will abolish or
simplify in the next 12 months
secondly
for the production of an electric car
dear friends
only half the number of employees is
needed
many industrial jobs in the european
union are under threat new jobs are
urgently needed in today's european
union
international trade wars and is a job
machine
why not now to pick up this debate with
our american friends let us negotiate an
eu us trade emergency program on the
mobility sector on mechanical
engineering in the digital economy
as soon as possible as a first step for
a more broader comprehensive trade
agreement and only this
will be
and only this will be the way to
strengthen the western economy key
industrial sectors and together we can
protect ourselves against china the
european union and the us together
represent 50 percent of the global
economy together we can start the growth
machine that benefits the whole world
thirdly dear friends the pandemic has
shown us how important the health sector
is
the coming decade will bring a wave of
innovation in medicine we can beat
cancer
i want europe to create 10 million new
jobs
in the next four years is an immediate
innovation offensive in this field at
the beginning of the digitalization 20
years ago vs europeans overslept the
innovation on internet and jobs were
created in the us and in china
today neither the chinese nor the
americans are ahead with the covet
vaccines but we are so let us use our
know-how right now
firstly defense
we and i fully welcome the initiatives
from mozilla on the line today and also
the resident of the defence council in
ljubljana but
what are we waiting for dear friends the
lisbon treaty gives us all options
if we want to create a reaction force so
let's do it and let's do it now
and fifthly dear friends
global responsibility
every day
15 000 people
sorry 15 000 children
die of hunger worldwide
every day
the everyday horror
and we hardly speak about it
the weakest suffer most from the covet
crisis
that is why we must reallocate and free
up france dear friends like we do it in
afghanistan now to invest
we need to stop the silent and daily
mass death on this world
and finally dear friends without law and
security the rest means nothing that is
why we stand for a robust application of
the rule of law mechanism inside of the
european union
but that is not enough cross-border tax
fraud money laundering and criminal
organizations mafia
make its way through our societies and
the terrorist threat is still high in
europe we don't why don't we finally
transform europol not into a real
european fbi and the european commission
should present in the next 12 months a
legislative package to strengthen
security in the european union with the
lafonda line was clear that we can lead
the world with a green deal
i want to put on the table that we have
to have the same ambitions now for new
jobs for our international
responsibility and for security let's do
it thank you
thank you
thank you very much mr berber now for
the group of socialist and democrats
iracia garcia perez
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
thank you
thank you miss garcia perez
next is mr dachan chalos for renew
europe
is elected
japan
european
[Applause]
replica
[Applause]
justice
um
[Applause]
[Applause]
the skin for perfect
college
possible do the right thing vote this
cap down
to pacquiao
for 55 years
energy
[Music]
is
the
capitalism
[Applause]
i passed the floor and now to jurg
mythen on behalf of the identity and
democracy group
for president
for our commission
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
opportunity
international
modification
and now i give the floor on behalf of
the left group for martin children
foreign
[Music]
scales
ferdinand jim duncan of maxim kate thank
you
mr devan
i now give the floor to tatiana begin by
remembering non-affiliate
commissary
[Music]
i now give the floor on behalf of the
council to mr angelou
honorable members
madam president of the commission
first of all on behalf of the council i
thank and congratulate
president vanderline for address a
strong and continued pro-european
conviction
interaction in this moment when the eu
is gradually recovering from the
pandemic
but facing great challenges in terms of
climate change and the international
situation your underlined strong soul is
needed
strong soul will be delivered from the
presidency side
we continue to be guided by the
strategic agenda 2019-2024
and in my view the slovenian presidency
priorities
fits perfectly well
with president on the line address today
during our presidency we are focusing in
particularly on building up health and
cyber resilience and also highlighting
the need to ensure resilience to any
type of crisis
covid showed that in the time of crisis
internal market and the full freedoms
come very fragile
therefore i believe that further
strengthening of the single market must
stay in our focus and an unhindered
functioning of the internal market is of
key importance for the european economy
regarding the health union intensive
work between the council and the
european parliament is ongoing
the council is working towards achieving
final agreement on the three proposals
in the package by the end of the year we
certainly need to use this political
momentum and to show our citizens that
together we are building a more silent
union that will be better prepared to
cope with future health crisis
we are welcoming the hera proposal
published yesterday i can assure you
that the slovenian presidency will make
every effort to advance negotiation we
see the hera proposal in complementary
with the health union package ladies and
gentlemen
let me use this opportunity to thank the
european commission for a strong
leadership in the past year that brought
us to a point where a successful vaccine
rollout has contributed to a
stabilization of the epidemiological
situation nonetheless due to the vaccine
hesitancy in many countries as well as
the threat of variants we will need to
remain cautious application of measures
to curb the spread of virus will be with
us for some time to come as with the
need to coordination of covet related
measures we intend to continue to ensure
a coordinated approach
vexing sharing with countries most in
need is an important gesture of
solidarity as presidency we will
therefore also do our best to contribute
to an accelerated efforts as regard eu
vaccine donation to third countries
dear members of the european parliament
prime minister yansha addressed you in
this hemi cycle in july and stated that
i quote the most important thing for our
short-term future is to stop the
pandemic and recover economically as
soon as possible the virus had put a
halt on social life and the economy for
the greater part of 2020 in 2021. it is
estimated that covet 19 took away more
than 5 million jobs in first half of
2020. the economy the eu economy has
shrunk by six percent yet in the second
quarter of 2021 we see remarkable
recovery across the eu
this recovery must include the green and
digital transition allow me to stress
the proposal on digital services and
digital markets
the council is working on both acts
intensively and we aim to agree
council's position by the end of the
year
us mrs wonderlion stated today digital
is a make or break issue
the presidency can only applaud to the
announcement of building a new eu cheap
ecosystem and new cyber security act
i would like to thank the commission for
the tremendous work on the fit for 55
package in very short time you presented
a huge legislative agenda across eu
policies and with far-reaching impact on
our economy industry and our way of life
all of this is also very important in
light of our preparation for the cop 26
in glasgow
it is never easy to change our social
and economic patterns even more so if
this implies higher cost for our
citizens therefore the social
consequences of this transition have to
be properly addressed so we complement
the announcement of new climate social
fund
we will walk together with the
commission to ensure that the council
swiftly endorse the necessary act for
the adoption of the national recovery
plans of the remaining member states and
the disbursement of funds these are
essential for recovery since the
beginning of the slovenian presidency we
have been able to approve 18 national
plans i'm convinced that this will
provide additional boost for the
european recovery ladies and gentlemen
all of these topics plus rule of law
strategic autonomy global action
migration and asylum back european
defense union all these will determine
our future and the future of next
generation for decades to ahead of us
this is why they are part of the
conference on the future of europe
discussion managed jointly by the
european parliament european commission
and
council
we should be able to ensure that we
engage with the and listen to our
citizens in search to answer the
question in what kind of europe they
wish to live these discussions should go
far beyond the brussels bubble
and far beyond our capitals i'm glad
that first citizens panel is about to
kick off at the end of this week it is
also important that when debating the
future of you we also look beyond
current borders process of enlargement
is taking place the region of western
balkans has eu perspective as presidency
slovenia pays special attention to the
western balkans the eu western balkans
summit will take place in slovenia in
october enlargement should be one of the
eu strategic priorities accession of the
western balkan country should be part of
our common vision
finally
we welcome the commission's letter of
intent which the council will discuss
next week together with the annual
foresight report we are convinced that
the report will be a useful tool not
only for political deliberation but also
for finding proper expert solution to
the issues
that the world of today and tomorrow
face
we look forward to continuing the
fruitful dialogue among the three
institutions on our common priorities
for the next year
the council will subsequently in
november discuss the new commissioned
work program with the view to the joint
declaration on legislative priorities
for 22. our joint program can help us
and our three institutions
achieve result in a focused and targeted
way let me reaffirm the council's
commitment to this process and assure
you that the presidency will continue to
be a determined partner
let me once again reassure
that presidency possessed a strong soul
european soul
and if you ask me
how to summarize today's state of the
union speech
in only three words
i would say
together
re-silent
europe
the exact motto of slovenian eu
presidency
thank you very much mr logar
i now give the floor to daniel caspari
for two minutes
is
150
foreign
[Applause]
it
foreign
dear madam president dear colleagues
as we start a new political year
we look back on a turbulent summer
we are still coping with the corona
epidemic
the american retreat from afghanistan
brought the taliban back to powers
and fears
back in the eyes of women and girls
we also saw flooding due to heavy
rainfall and extreme heat on our own
continent
this summer has reminded us there is
still much to be done
on geopolitics
climate
health
digital security our role in the world
and migration to name a few
there is a need
for a strong
european cooperation
i think the coming political year should
revolve around one word
deliver
deliver on our role in a world that is
increasingly unstable
deliver on climate policies to cut down
emissions
meet our climate target in 2015 and
adapt to new climate situations
deliver on digital
deliver on security for our citizens and
standing for our common values and the
protection of the rule of law
and democracy
using all instruments available
deliver on migration to prevent people
from taking dangerous routes that take
them a long way from home and possibly
alive
in uncertainty
deliver or revitalize the european union
with the conference of the future of
europe with our citizens at its core
dear madam president
your commission is almost halfway
and the next half must be about
delivering
there is enough opportunity to do so and
today we call on you to do so
not only words but action and
implementation in your introduction you
mentioned also that you already have
delivered but for your new europe it's
not enough
but let me also turn me to my colleagues
we as european parliament also have to
deliver to meet the expectations of our
citizens
last week we as renewed published our
roadmap in paris
for the coming months and extended our
hand to all those in the european
parliament that wants to deliver
let me ask you all
are you ready to take that
responsibility with us like a
parliamentary majority and deliver on
all of those important issues
we as renew are ready and it's time to
deliver to deliver
deliver thank you
[Applause]
um
thank you chairman madam president the
pandemic has shown that when european
institutions take the lead in facing
common challenges the eu
can deliver results vaccine development
and purchase the cobit certificate next
generation eu despite some initial flows
what has been achieved so far is truly
remarkable
with a terrible contradiction though
that we now have millions of doses
waiting in our in the freezers while in
many other countries vaccination has
hardly begun so we need to step up our
solidarity
if we were to face all the big
challenges with the same leadership and
determination then as a union we would
achieve much more
and we know we don't lack challenges for
instance many of our european companies
are in a race against time
to maintain their competitiveness
despite growing demand they face rising
energy and raw material prices shortage
of components and fair competition from
third countries and we cannot achieve
the goals of the green deal without them
let's support our industry with an
ambitious strategy let's translate the
strategic autonomy into something more
than just fancy words
on another note madam ponder lion today
the catalan and spanish governments are
formally resuming negotiations on how to
solve the ongoing political conflict
between catalonia and spain i know you
will argue this is an internal matter
but we will know this is not entirely
true
the eu should follow this negotiation
and embrace it as much as much as it can
because in a democratic space as we want
the european union to be
conflicts on self-determination require
a democratic and negotiated solution
other
authoritarian-like responses have no
place in our union thank you
a
b
[Applause]
not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Applause]
[Applause]
dear vice president pedro silva prayer
dear colleagues dear
president madam president of the
commission
the puerto social summit was not a
beauty contest
that means that from now on we must take
every chance to implement the social
pillar objectives in europe we need the
reduction of poverty to be at the
forefront of european policies
unfortunately i have to say i didn't see
it high up in your priorities today
that is why this group is clearly
calling for an anti-poverty law in
europe with clear binding targets to
improve the lives of millions of people
is the commission ready to respond to
such a strong commitment madam president
moreover we need all resources we can
get to fight poverty and inequalities we
need economic reforms and rules that
push for green and social investments to
pursue sustainable well-being for all
that is also why we pushed for the
recovery plans to focus on the social
conditions the commission must ensure
that this is a true priority because we
were not in porto for the photos or the
beautiful weather we were there to make
a difference for the future
if you were also there
for the same reasons as we did this is
the time to set your priorities
correctly madam president we want
the the end of extreme poverty to become
one of your biggest endeavors we cannot
be clear on this matter from the side of
our uh political family thank you so
much
[Applause]
going to abrigad
stefan
europe
[Music]
[Music]
responsibility
[Applause]
a
gracias
[Music]
um
dear president
usually from the line
you talk about the need for a socially
just
transition
but what is the reality
tens of thousands of construction
workers risk
losing their lives in the green
transition if protections against the
deadly asbestos
do not go hand in hand with the
renovation wave of millions of buildings
in europe
i thought the commission was committed
to a vision zero of work-related deaths
but yesterday i
as a reporter on the asbestos file
received this letter from the commission
warning against the lowering of the
limit value even though we all know
this will save lives
dear president
we do not need sweet words on a socially
just transition
we need
action
[Applause]
um
thank you mr president president fonder
line welcome back to the european
parliament dear colleagues over the
course of the last year we have made
together far-reaching decisions we have
together overcome the most difficult
part of the pandemic we have together
made decisions to help
those people affected by the pandemic
and to make sure that the european union
will be stronger in the future exactly
one year ago we had the will to act
together but we did not have the tools
we did not have a vaccine we did not
have an eu vaccination plan in place we
did not have a budget for the european
union for the next years and we did not
have a recovery plan in place due to our
common action over the course of the
last year all of these elements are in
place and now we have these tools in
place now we have to make sure that
particularly in helping
the people and the economy recover money
from the european level is well spent
and i have madam president two calls to
make firstly
we have to think when and how we pay
back um the amounts from a next
generation eu and we have to make sure
that we pay these back without affecting
the budget of the european union in the
future without needing to tell farmers
students or researchers that we have
less money for them and the common
answer which we have agreed council
commission and parliament is to go for
own resources of the european union to
provide stability for the financing of
the european union in the future and
this is why madam president i kindly
asked the commission to make a proposal
as we have discussed on a digital levy
on the current border adjustment tax and
on a revision of the european trading of
the emission trading system soon over
the course of the next weeks and
secondly dear colleagues
we also have to progress with greening
and digital we cannot afford to put that
transition on towards the green economy
on small and medium-sized enterprises
and also on people affected by higher
bills for electricity
specifically the most vulnerable
citizens particularly in this global
context of increased energy prices i
call upon the commission i ask us all
together to make sure that we use all
the instruments which we have at our
disposal and create new instruments if
needed to help the vulnerable citizens
on this transition to the green economy
as during the pandemic we have to be on
the side of the people thank you very
much
[Applause]
not
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
colleagues
firstly i would like to complement the
commission for the extraordinary
achievement of tackling the enormous
challenges of the pandemic
regarding our economies the recovery
facility proved to be a strong tool to
ease the strain of member states
as the latest surveys show a big
majority of our citizens have faith in
the facility
but 85 percent also expect transparency
and effective control to you on the use
of such funds
now in hungary today we have an
authoritarian government that
effectively uses european funds to
deconstruct rule of law the finance
minister of which already openly
speculates on leaving the eu if finances
are withheld while the two-thirds
majority of hungarian citizens are
pro-european
these are the desperate cries of the
crumbling regime
madame fonda lyon i listened carefully
to your nice words on european values
but also heard the gobbledygook on
safeguarding them
you have a clear mandate
you have an instrument the rule of law
mechanism which is effective as of 1st
of january please use it thank you
for watching
[Applause]
is
foreign
foreign
thank you very much mr chair madam
president
i want to say that you're indeed right
that the eu has weathered the past year
many better than many had expected we
caught up in vaccination rates with the
leading countries around the world and
our economic recovery is underway of
course we still have ways
to go to defeat covet both in europe
and abroad but the eu has indeed proved
many of its doubters wrong
looking ahead though what myself and
many of my colleagues are especially
concerned is the continuing democratic
backsliding in several member states
president wanda lyon spoke about various
ambitions that the eu should pursue from
health care to military capacity from
climate change to social policy and of
course i support all these ambitions but
the success
of any of these future projects relies
on a shared bed of principles and values
none of these programs will that the
president outline will will be
successful
will work well in the long run if the
european union turns into a disjointed
club of democracies and other regime
types because the trust we need the
mutual trust we need to sustain these
initiatives and of course this
sense of purpose to drive them will
evaporate if this is not the case
because what we're seeing today the
suppression of critical voices
state-sponsored hate campaigns attacks
on independent institutions all of this
suggests that some of our members of our
community are increasingly drifting away
and the eu of course must recognize that
the orchestrators of these liberal
developments are first and foremost
government's elite while citizen support
for the eu remains very high in both
hungary and poland
this is why the european commission
needs to take action as we have called
for it needs to put a fight for its
values because if we don't we would
never have the political strength and
the cohesion to move forward with these
ambitious projects
therefore president from the lion rule
of law and democracy is not just another
agenda among many it's not just another
box to take not just another paragraph
in a speech it's a precondition for
anything else we want to do together
thank you very much
[Applause]
for watching
mercy
um
[Music]
b
um
foreign
foreign
stability
um
[Music]
um
thank you for speaking so quietly of the
union's challenges with allah too bad
that you were not
very precise but i presume you were
referring to spain
yes mr sanchez is not talking of
dialogue yes nine political prisoners
are finally home after years in jail but
the prosecution of catalan dissidents
including state espionage of political
opponents goes on and relenting
yesterday it was announced that 13
activists will have to stand trial on
accused terrorism charges that are
totally fabricated so what is mr sanchez
proposal political and cultural
repression economic suffocation
submission
but the catalan people will not give in
to fear on saturday hundreds of
thousands march on the streets of
savannah their message was loud and
clear we catalans have the right to
self-determination and we voted to be
independent on october 1st 2017.
no other political movement in europe
mobilizes popular support and has the
resilience of the catalan cause in spite
of spanish repression in spite of the
institutions of europe indifference we
shall overcome thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
next is marek belka for one and a half
minutes
madame chair
and i'm president
the last two years were a testing time
for the european union
but here we are
we are still standing
however the next year must bring us
decisions on various
important topics
first
how to reform stability and growth pact
in the short term we still need to
address the health social and economic
consequences of covet
yes we must return to stability criteria
but this requires a transition
a premature withdrawal of stimulating
measures will only harm our economies
in the long term the fiscal rules need
to change so that they will not kill
investment and growth
we have a pandemic behind us and digital
and climate transition ahead an
ambitious focus on a digital and green
revolution needs flexibility in the
rules and this is what we will insist on
from the trade perspective we expect the
commission to be engaged in the process
of reactivating the negotiating function
of the wto
ensuring the proper functioning of the
dispute settlement mechanism and making
sure that we can better address future
value chain distortions
finally
we insist on the introduction and
implementation of the mandatory due
diligence rules aimed at all companies
in the eu market
which actions cause harm to the
environment workers and human rights
the upcoming year should bring us change
we hope that with this commission it
will also have a social dimension at
heart
thank you
thank you very much mr belka next is
dita ranzova um for two minutes vice
president flores
thank you madam president dear
colleagues this has been an incredibly
tough year
but we are now seeing delight at the end
of the tunnel and looking to our
economic recovery
we need to get back on our two feet and
regain competitiveness
as soon as possible
we now have the money
but the policies we adopt and the kind
of business environment we create will
determine how we emerge from the crisis
and how quickly
the approach we take on digital and
climate transitions are key
while we shape this new digital decade
we must be careful to avoid over
regulating which will just hold our
companies especially smes back
we need them to be free to innovate and
thus grow
we must find the isolationism
protectionism tendencies in the name of
european sovereignty
we can be strong
and
open to the world
we can have strategic crisis reserves
but still be open to free trade and open
industry
without a global alliance we will just
fall more behind other world powers
now is not the time to hide but to get
into the game
we all want to protect the environment
but we have to take into account the
impact on the lives of our citizens
it was a mistake to include private
houses in the ets and we need to fix it
the policies we adopt in brussels must
be about making lives better
both for our citizens and our
businesses
we must make policy with
and for our citizens
not against them thank you very much
thank you very much uh mr lance of our
next is bazaar cult for one minute
thank you very much and thank you madam
president for your state of the union
which had quite some a lot of good
proposals but of course in one minute i
will have to focus on the criticism uh
you you you will
understand that first of all on the
green deal you probably still have to
explain your own group that the green
deal is the jobs deal they still don't
get that
so work to be done there as well but
also in your own college i have the
feeling that that some of your
colleagues are feeling a bit like oh
after fit for 55 our work is done the
work is only begunning and for example
on stay date we do expect also that here
the commission is delivering so i'm
looking also at madame vestager for that
on corona vaccination it was a bit too
self-congratulatory
because the global vaccination that is
our key challenge now and here kovacs is
not enough mentioning a state of the
union without using the word patent is a
bit of a problem and last point on the
rule of law you absolutely had good
words on that but now you have to apply
the instruments that you have since the
first of january because the rule of law
is really our basis of a european union
with the soul that you want thank you
very much
thank you mr ike house next is peter
covford for one minute
[Music]
foreign
hello
[Music]
thank you
next is martin sonobon for one minute
[Music]
thank you
next is eva mydel for two minutes
foreign
thank you very much miss mydell next is
eric andrea for one minute and a half
[Music]
i now give the floor to vice president
nicola for two minutes
trp
thank you very much next is silvia
spurak for one minute
thank you
[Music]
the next is angel damboski for one
minute
kolakuswich for one minute
of wonderland
for two minutes
is
thank you mr anjen next is sergey
stanley chef for one and a half minutes
thank you
chair madam president commissioners
in the last year and a half we all lived
under the dark shadow of covet 19 crisis
but europe withstood it we did fairly
well
however
now we're entering the most important
period the period of delivery
because we have an unprecedented
instrument in our hands this is the next
generation eu recovery package
but we
need to work hard in order to make it a
success and there are three major
criteria and preconditions to make it
happen
first we don't need to come to the
situation before the crisis
we need the recovery to lead to a
sustainable
development economy and society for
europe both
environmentally and socially second
if we want the green and the digital
transitions to be successful we need to
provide the tools that it is just
and we need resources in order to make
the buffers and protect those who will
suffer
thirdly
rule of law and democracy are paramount
importance for the socialists you now as
commission have all the instruments to
provide them in the use of the resources
of the fund so please use them if we
follow these three preconditions and
criteria i think that in one year we
shall be even more optimistic about the
future thank you very much
thank you very much next is sophie
indeweld for one and a half minutes
thank you madam chair president
frondelle and you have today presented a
list of ambitious plans but in its
current state the european union cannot
deliver
we support most of your plans
wholeheartedly but intergovernmental
europe is sclerotic and paralyzed and
the european council has become the
graveyard of many crucial initiatives
migration pact stuck geopolitics europe
is a [ __ ] rule of law talk talk no
action and europe is quietly but
steadily losing ground in the global
economy the green deal is a great plan
but national governments have already
started to unpick it and pick it
you mentioned rightfully the lack of
political will but let me finish that
sentence for you the lack of political
will of the national governments
yet the commission is making itself the
most loyal servant of the council while
community europe has been losing ground
but dear colleagues let's also look at
ourselves
if the commission is cozying up to the
council it's because it smells where the
power is
and it is up to this house to restore
the democratic balance the separation of
powers and checks and balances
parliament should not just be a good
legislator but also take its tasks as
parliamentary watchdog more seriously
because our ambitions the ambitions that
we share cannot be made reality with a
limping democracy and this house has
therefore to drastically up its game in
the next couple of years because only a
strong political union can take europe
forward thank you
thank you miss and felt next is sven
gigold for one minute
for our commissions president and liber
colleague and colleague europa's
by
thank you mr gilgold next is christian
terres for one minute
thank you
the president from the lion in 2019 as a
candidate for the office that you are
holding right now you said in this
plenary and i quote the foundation of
our european civilization is greek
philosophy and roman law
what you did not mention
in that speech is the founder is the
fundamental role that christianity and
implicitly the judeo-christian values
had in developing the european
civilization
based on these christian values and the
belief that all human beings are created
in the image of god
the fundamental and inalienable rights
were developed which later was specified
in treaties and conventions as well as
national constitutions and laws
reducing the european civilization only
to greek philosophy and roman law and
ignoring the judeo-christian values
you'll find arguments for inequality and
slavery as he was in the ancient greeks
greek and tyranny as he was in the
ancient rome
under your rulership unfortunately the
european union became from an area of
freedom a concentration camp in which
people cannot travel eating restaurants
or go to movies unless they have a green
certificate i urge you therefore to
promote and defend in the european union
the christian heritage and values based
on which we are created by god equal and
born free thank you thank you mr there
has next is dorian rockmaker for one
minute
thank you chair
today the president of the european
commission set out the agenda for the
coming year
the agenda is hyper ambitious
the president speaks of the team eu but
we have never been more divided
action is reaction
if the commission tries to force member
states with legal actions
it will only create more opposition
you may not like or trust orban or
morowitzki
but the majority of voters do
and we have to
respect democracy
second transparency is key
every eu eu citizen should be able to
see what's going on
the technique is available
we can start tomorrow
finally to create a real working union
we must connect in real life free
movement of persons by high-speed rail
that creates a world of opportunity for
all
it's green it's accessible and it's safe
respect transparency and tangible
results
this will bring europe closer together
thank you
next is
esther de lange for one and a half
minutes
and let me maybe take this image of a
house that needs renovation
and apply it to our european house to
our european union and in many areas
indeed that house is strong
we added an extra room in the area of
health when we face an unprecedented
health threats
but the house also needs a strong
foundation the rule of law independent
courts and independent media i thank the
commission for the initiatives announced
in this area today but like the pandemic
the rule of law is not a sprint but a
marathon and this house expects the
european commission to go all the way
and let me
finalize uh today's contribution by
saying that we also need fixing our roof
when it's not yet raining i'm thinking
about the creation of a capital markets
union the completion of the banking
union how matter
no matter how difficult that will be so
let's get to work thank you
thank you
very much uh mr langa next
afghanistan
next is hildevartmance for one minute
colleegas
thank you
next is ludek niedermeier for one minute
and a half
thank you very much madam chair madam
president dear colleagues dear guests
i guess we can be very proud for things
we have done
last year i just hope
we
save more lives
reduce the suffering and save some costs
but now we must face the future
and here i must say that i share an
agree the agenda the program presented
by you madam president commented by
manfred weber and the others and i like
a lot of people in this house i believe
we can deliver on this program if we
want
let me share some points that were
discussed and i haven't heard a lot
a reaction in discussion first on
microchips here i guess time is money
and we must find a way how to help our
researchers investors and firms to
increase our sovereignty and support our
economy the example to follow is not
just galileo it's also battery alliance
that i guess is doing very well second i
was very pleased to hear that human
rights are not for sale as you said at
no cost
i guess yesterday was too late to make
it more real i guess to start with ban
on certain export is the first step but
just the first step and i guess we must
deliver on that finally last not least
let me refer to next generation eu and
rrf i guess this was a very right
decision in right time let me just
remind commission and council that there
should be no space only not for
corruption conflict of interest and
wrongdoing but we must make sure that
money will deliver that's the key how to
turn this brave decision into success
thank you
thank you mr niedermeyer next is javier
moreno sanchez for one minute